يستمع قضاه ومحققونا اوروبيون لشهود
اللبنانيين في قضايا فسادى وطبيب اموال
واثراء غير مشروع وسط اجراءات الامنيه
مشدده امام قصر العدل عمليه الاستماع
التجري باشراف القضاء اللبناني المختصه هو
في الطبقه الرابعه تحديدا من هذا المبنى
الاساسي للقضاء اللبناني يقول هؤلاء بانهم
سيستمعون لتكوين فكره اا اكبر وتكوين ملف
اضافي للتحقيقات التي يجرونها بشان عمليات
تبييض اموال ويقول الطرف اللبناني بانه
قتل للطلب الاوروبي بناءا لاتفاقيه مكافحه
الفساد الدوليه التي وقع عليها لبنان عام
2008 بعد ذلك سيقوم الوفد القضايا
الاوروبي بتوجيه اتهامات في حاله الوصول
الى معلومات اضافيه بحق الشهود وربما بحق
اشخاص اخرين اجتمع العشرات من اللبنانيين
امام قصر العدل
القضاء اللبناني على القيام بدوره ومكافحه
الفساد وايضا على قيام الاتحاد الاوروبي
من خلال قضواته بملاحقه الفاسدين في لبنان
وفق مقاله والذين حاولوا اموال الى عدد من
الدول الاوروبيه وفقا ادعاء هؤلاء لذلك
فان القضاء اللبناني يريد ايضا الوصول الى
نتائج اضافيه قد تمهد لادعاء على اشخاص في
حال اتبين من خلال التحقيقات بان هناك
عمليات تبييض اموال وايضا عمليات اسراء
غير مشروع لبنانيين حولوا اموال الى خارج
البلاد
ايهاب العقلي الجزيره بيروت